can you hear me now I'm going to talk
and you can pay attention to her are you
comparing fixing to make gonads are
useful for their purpose but they are no
substitute for brains let's take out the
shovel clean up one thank you
god bless you and God bless the United
States of America why does the media
attack an issue to get primetime ratings
and watch what happens in this week when
it's sweeps week
they host that a child is molested by a
rabbi was an affair with a cow it's time
for insensitivity training with work
McCowan and Joe Murphy hello everybody
and welcome to insensitivity training
I'm Court McGowan Joe bartnik still in
Canada but that doesn't mean that I
didn't find a very special guest for our
podcast today I've traveled all the way
up into the Hollywood Hills up to where
people that well they're well off
they're well off they're nice they're
comfortable and then we find this house
no I'm kidding we're up at a good friend
of Mines house and I I can't thank you
enough for doing the podcast ladies and
gentlemen the one the only mr. Harlan
Williams
yes buddy how are you sir I'm great but
it's good good good to be on the pod
it's good to have it's good to have you
on the pod man I think you did it with
us a couple years ago yeah I think we
did one over at the all things comedy
studios right now and in Joe's been on
the road so I've been been trying to
find people that I could you know have
on the podcast while he's gone and fill
in and and wow what a job already you've
done I am you know I think I've said
three sentences and I feel real solid
yeah I feel really solid about it to be
a good pod bro it's gonna be a good time
it's going to Excel brow we just I want
to there's one thing I want to talk
about because you are known for one is
is you have such of and I don't want to
say Mitch because that's not the word
you have such a wonderful comedy
sona in other words you are there's one
there's only one Harlan Williams there's
there's there's nobody that does comedy
like you there's nobody that there's
there's no way to describe what you do
you just go what you just got to see
Harlan I just got to see it and and
we've worked together for I mean oh
you're saying this now that we work
together for almost ten years that's
right off and on and we just I just got
the pleasure of doing opening for you in
Irvine and you produced or you start and
produced and wrote and did come up with
this this caramel corn the pun yes we
tell the listeners a little bit about
this well it's it's my latest stand-up
comedy special and it's it's me doing
stand-up comedy as a dog so I I do a
full hour special of my act but I found
this incredible mask of a pug that
covers my whole head and face and the
mouth articulate so that when I move my
real mouth the mouth on the mask moves
and so for all intensive purposes it
just looks like a you know a human with
a dog head or a dog with a human body
and I I was kind of you know I always
try to challenge myself on my specials I
always kind of want to do something that
pushes me pushes the audience and so I
thought man I found this mask in a shop
and I put it on and I was like in my
head the fur I just went bingo this is
my next special I'm doing it as a dog so
I made up the name caramel corn the Pug
and and there we went did you where did
you fight which shop did you find this
it was like a cheesy little Halloween
store in a strip mall in Pittsburgh I
was doing a show around Pittsburgh and I
was I was killing some time just walking
around I go and it was right around
Halloween obviously and I went in and I
I saw this mask hanging on the wall and
I was like I'll try it on I like pogs I
like dog and then when I saw that the
mouth moved and it kind of moved in
unison with my mouth it just made me
laugh I was like this is the weirdest
wildest thing I've ever
Sene and i thought i'd been searching
for inspiration for my next comedy
special yeah my last one I did out in
the desert on a hill in the middle of
the day with my audience which by the
way you've got to see because it's
basically you on a hilltop screaming
right though at the the heavens yeah so
to speak yeah it is there's some that is
that is of wild it is a while it was a
lot of fun for me and I really pushed me
and challenged me and and so I was like
how do I beat that and then I put this
mask on and I was like really happy
because I was honestly getting a bit
frustrated it'd been like three or four
years since I did a force of nature the
outdoor one and then when I put this
mask on I was just like that holy grails
like oh you know I was like yeah here we
go I'm not my next special I'm a dog so
caramel corn the Pug was born and it
wasn't that long that you started you
came up with the idea that you actually
did the special that's right yeah I just
found the mask about a year ago and I
thought I wasn't sure if it would work
or not so I started I started opening
for myself on the road what I'd do is
I'd have an emcee then I'd come out as
caramel corn and do like five or six
minutes just to test it and then I'd
bring the opening act out and then I'd
come out again and some of the people in
the crowd didn't know it was me as
caramel corn so they're seeing me twice
so I would do some old material so that
they want I won't be repeating material
and it you know the little that it was
funny because I only did five or six
minutes while testing it and it got last
but I got to be honest I think I told
you the day we shot the special I was
quite terrified because I didn't know if
I could do it for an hour I knew I could
talk in the mask for an hour but I
didn't know if the audience would stay
with me for an hour and amazingly we did
two tapings that day we did an eighth
and they stayed with me I call whole
time they were they were and a lot of
people didn't know it was you yeah yeah
a lot of validation I was you it was it
was one of the funnest things I've ever
seen
and and the weird thing too is is it was
so hot in that mask oh god yeah well the
top part of the costume was
full mass that covers my whole head and
it's fur you know it's a fur mass so
it's very hot and then to keep the
neckline of the mask concealed I had to
wear a turtleneck sweater so now I've
got a blue turtleneck sweater I look
like I should be a ski instructor in
Switzerland and then to complete the
look I found this really kind of weird
wool jacket
I noticed that so I've got a wool jacket
a a blue turtleneck sweater a pug hat on
and it's I'm under these hot lights in a
theater with over 500 people yeah and I
got to tell you man it was it was like
playing like a game of hockey with my
hockey helmet on I was sweating buckets
but you know it feels good I a lot of
people go wasn't that horrible wasn't
that a it's kind of like when you're in
the midst of a tennis game or you're
doing something that's really aggressive
and you're in the flow and you fend the
sweat kind of feels good yeah because
you know you're working and you know
there's passion and you know there's
energy and and so I all that sweat just
kind of fueled me it felt really great
under there
well I both shows we're amazing it's
going to come out when it comes out
definitely keep an eye out for it and
then the other thing you've been really
busy doing is your cartoon I know back
more pugs can you believe it you got
just you got pugs everywhere
it's potty don't you dream pugs now well
it's weird because I just got offered a
part in a movie I can't say what it is
yet but it's a a movie that's going to
be kind of like a puppet animated puppet
movie and they cast me and then they
sent me some artwork and it's a pug Wow
and then I just got a call back this
week for a TV show where they they're
talking to me about doing the voice and
a new cartoon and it's a dog so it's
like everything's dogs and you know I
have this show called puppy dog pals on
Disney that that that's you know you
created and I created you wrote you
designed to carry I mean you yeah I
shouldn't say designed to carry but you
came up with all the characters and all
the Care helped design the characters
live know once I sold it to Disney
we got a whole amazing team on board and
we all kind of worked on it together but
yeah we got 50 episodes and it's on the
air and the kids are loving it it's it's
it's for Disney Junior it's for life or
guys that smoke a lot of weed got
nothing else to do so it's for like two
- like 9 year olds or whatever but or 22
year olds - 38 year olds that are
unemployed and exactly and have a pot
problem yeah exactly
okay any of those categories and you're
golden but it's it's been a blast and
Disney does such an amazing like you
know a lot of times in Hollywood you get
on a project and you go I hope it comes
out the way I envisioned it and it's not
it's not often unfortunately where it
comes out better than what you thought
it would be and this this cartoon I did
with Disney puppy dog pals actually came
out better than what I thought but it's
not a surprise because you know Disney
so good at what they do so now you have
a long history in Hollywood of doing
some of the biggest movies Dumb and
Dumber Something About Mary half-baked
Rocket Man I mean some some very very
well-known movies feminine or not I mean
if you ever say Rocket Man people know
what it is yeah you know Dumb and Dumber
I thinks where you got your start is
that right with the Farrelly Brothers
movie up is now you've had a lot of good
experiences in Hollywood I would imagine
yeah yeah if you ever had any a really
bad experience in Hollywood like on a
movie yeah yeah I mean and and and you
don't have to say the movies I say it
I'll say it because I would never knock
a movie just for the sake of knocking it
but I would knock it for honest reasons
and I took a movie that I did called
surf school and it's just whenever you
attach the word school to a movie you
know and I wasn't going to do it it was
it was basically what it sounds like a
bunch of young kids learning to surf and
I was like the old veteran seasoned
surfer dude you know but it was a rip
and it was a cool character yeah but I I
knew that it was one of kind of these
cheesy movies
but all of a sudden you know I I said
alright I'll meet with the director and
I met with the director and he said look
man you're going to be the highest-paid
guy on the movie you're gonna make good
dough you're going for ten days to Costa
Rica we're filming on the beach with a
bunch of fun young kids actors a bunch
of girls in bikinis you're on the beach
all paid for ten days and I just went
you know normally I don't do a movie
unless it's something artistically I can
get into or I like and I thought you
know I could I could use that kind of
vacation yeah and and actually the
character was cool too I character in
the script gave me a lot of room to do
what I like to do with characters but I
knew it was kind of a lower budget thing
and I you know it wasn't like with a
studio but I took it and I went and and
the movie and I'm not saying this to be
mean but if you hold it up against my
other movies it's probably the worst
movie I did but I had a great time doing
it I don't think it was cut together
well I don't think it the story was
executed well but you know I give
everyone a for effort and movies are not
easy to make and and I had a blast and
it is what it is but if I if I had to
you know put a scale of my worst movies
of my unfortunately that one's probably
at the bottom alright now that I get now
let me ask you this have you ever had a
bad even maybe it's a good movie ever
had a bad experience were like everybody
I mean sometimes people have like that
like you go to a location it's supposed
to be this innit
I mean I remember I was working on a
thing and this low-budget movie which
I've done a bunch of really bad ones and
I won't even name names because they're
so many are bad but but I remembered
like we're supposed to like you know
it's sag and it's all this time you just
it's Union I should say but those you
don't end and you know you're supposed
to have like a dressing room and it's
not like you're supposed to have a
dressing room like a big lavish thing
it's you're just supposed to have a
place because when you go do a movie
most of the time you know you're there
for 12 to 14 hours in a day and you
really only work for about 30 minutes
time and really actually their own the
other time you're just sitting around
and sometimes unit so they you're
supposed to have a place where you can
go hang out and you know sleep if you
near whatever learn a private you know
whatever it is trailer you know your
honey wagon or whatever it is and and I
went it did one in there was no honey
wagons there was no nothing and we were
all sitting in this person's living room
oh and it was like what on location on
location in a living room that the air
conditioning really didn't work very
good and it was like stuffy and there
was like people walking if you ever had
a bad experience I didn't have that I
shot a movie with a movie I adore by the
way I called because of winn-dixie oh
yeah has a great movie with Jeff Daniels
and who's that in dese folks of the
singer guy via these huge e tours all
over the place I forget his name but he
was in it and it was just it was such a
charming wonderful movie but
unfortunately it took place in a small
town in the book the story is real
quickly about a little girl whose mother
has died from alcoholism and the
father's trying to help keep the family
together and the girl finds a dog in a
winn-dixie which is a grocery store in
the south and she leaves don't tell me
the dog dies no the dog doesn't know
John names the dog winn-dixie I'll see a
movie because of winn-dixie and so we
had to shoot in this little small town
in Louisiana called Napoleon Ville oh
it's like a sugar cane town it's like
now a little tiny town sugar cane fields
ever really quite I love small towns I
have its there and a place you drive
through and go oh my god I want to take
pictures I want to buy and yet there's
no Starbucks and it's off the grid it's
great it's charming but unfortunately
the whole movie was shot there and there
was there was only one hotel a motel 6
and and I think there was a Howard
Johnson's which you rarely find anymore
and you know we had to put the whole
crew there so I came in I think I was on
the movie for 10 days and I just stay in
a motel
Exce middle of summer million degrees in
this little town and I just I was just
going through my divorce
so I all it was one of the most
depressing times of my life I was very
depressed because of my divorce and so I
was I loved being on the movie but then
I had to go back to the motel 6 and you
know there's a we're right near the
coast where all these oil rigs are see
I'd walk to my room and out side of
every room would be a pair of oil
covered muddy rubber galoshes from the
oil rig workers that were staying in all
the other it was just and I was just it
wasn't anything to do with the movie it
was just a place I was in in my life and
it was really just I know just I was
just depressed and I was trapped in a
motel 6 and the bed was crunchy and
there was a glory hole in the ceiling
and I woke up covered in someone else's
psoriasis scab it's just like that not
the nicest motels know so that was kind
of a crappy time yeah that doesn't sound
like a good time the good news is that
the movie came out beautifully it was
wonderful and I had a great time doing
it yeah yeah well yeah they didn't have
much of a choice they didn't have any
choice other than build a new hotel yeah
and if I had been in a better place
mentally I wasn't going through what I
was going through it probably would have
been just fine now let me ask you this
one question of did Jeff Daniels stay at
the motel 6 no Jeff Daniels B Welton
they rented a house we did two things
Jeff Daniels drove down because he lives
up and I think Massachusetts or whatever
it's called to chooses yeah yeah he
drove down in his big giant like RV oh
why why wasn't there an RV for her--let
it was his own he owned it I know but
they could have rented one for Harlan
and then the other guy brought his tour
bus the rock guy is a huge guy I can't
remember his name
not our low Guthrie no he's a white like
a folk folk singer guy tour guy but
anyways he brought his tour bus and so
they had that plus they got Jeff Daniels
I think they got him a house course they
did yeah
so you couldn't you couldn't stay in
that's trailer while he was camped out
in the house nobody we hung out in his
trailer a little bit but yeah he did you
go
did you ever Dave Matthews that's the
name of the owner he was in the movie
with with us yeah hey Matthew no he
brought her to her boss and this was run
Dave Matthews was that kind of his peak
so I think they're still peeking there's
very great so if he was a super great
guy we hung out we ever in like Jeff's
trailer just sitting there and kind of
and kind of looking around and
everything go sure you got a nice
trailer I'm off to the motel yeah
they give him a guilt trip yeah it's
just a little just a little nudge I
should've I didn't know I we were too
busy reminiscing about Dumb and Dumber
and it was it was like it was like the
next movie I did with him after Dumb and
Dumber so oh that's very kind of neat to
be back working with Jeff again you know
and you still get recognized a lot from
Dumb and Dumber oh I'll wait Rocketman
and then and then I one of the things I
want to ask you about because it's such
he's become such a huge star is
Chappelle is you guys did half-baked to
get out with you jim breuer Dave
Chappelle queer mo Diaz yeah
and was that like was I mean you're not
I know I've known you for a long time
you're not a big pothead
no no you know but Dave likes to smoke
yeah Dave likes to smoke Jim likes to
smoke yeah I don't know if they still do
but at that time they did yeah it was it
kind of like was that it was that it set
where everyone was smoking a lot uh you
know I don't think that people were
smoking on set but I think like
afterwards people were smoking and yeah
your regular pot smokers absolutely
you're going to do but I mean it's
possible maybe those guys were smoking
on so I never saw no no I don't mean I
don't mean it like that I just mean was
it a set like I don't mean when I say on
set during work hours but one of those
sets where after everyone kind of just
fires up and you know it's like in end
of the day and it's like you can kind of
you can kind of see the cloud moving
away from the set you know well the
thing is we were all staying at a pretty
fancy hotel in Toronto so very different
than the motel six yeah exactly and
and so so you know as far as what people
did after hours I'm not sure but we had
a few parties you know we'd hang out in
Dave's room or Jim's room or my room and
so there was definitely some some smoke
clouds blowing around but I couldn't
tell you if it was every night or every
day but but at that point in time I
think Dave was quite into the weed
because you know he co-wrote that movie
so he had to be in the dope to make a
movie about dope I would I would think
so yeah I would think so now have you
seen days now they just released a
series and Netflix but that's right
do you watch the Netflix you watch a lot
of comedy or not no you don't don't I
rarely watch I've not seen Dave's I
rarely watch stand-up comedy specials
now this is what I do want to know what
does Harlan Williams like to sit around
and watch what inspires you I love
nature shows man I love to what I'll
watch nature shows for hours
I love what I get fascinated I'll watch
it an hour show about ants a lot to show
about lions I'll watch a show about
praying mantises I'll watch a show about
fisheye and I just love watching nature
and its elements I love I love watching
the way animals are built on the way
they move and the way they you know the
guy just I'm a nature show nut yeah
that's amazing
it I just love it amazing yeah amazing I
mean it your eye I think if you ever get
a chance to watch Harlan do stand-up you
are you're doing yourselves a serious
disservice if you don't get out and
watch him because you have some new
jokes you've been doing about about
nature a lot about that one of them is
actually about nature nature show
watching yeah yeah and I and I literally
absolutely I love them I love them so oh
thank you well there's one I do where I
didn't think people would get it because
I do this joke about you know being
being in an alley looking for something
to eat and a guy a meth-head pulls up on
me with a gun and ask for my wallet and
I'm like oh man I'm trapped in an alley
how do I get out of this and so I go I
thought this is how I get out of it I
start making baby alligator noises you
know
and I didn't think anyone would get it
but from watching nature shows I know
that when baby alligators emerge from
the eggs they call for their mother they
may wait what if the life is like out
out cat it's a weird it's a weird like
chirp and the mother hears it and she
comes and she she helps excavate the the
babies from the mound because she buries
the egg so she helps dig them up and
then she protects and they actually sit
in her mouth while he serves around the
little babies well they crawl she picks
them up in the giant mouth and she's
very delicate and these little tiny
babies are hanging out of her mouth and
they're protected and so I thought
nobody's going to know what baby
alligator noises are right and I guess
maybe they do or they don't but I guess
they're funny and so and so I do this
bit where I go how do I get this I'll
start making baby alligator noise so I'm
like out to the to the meth head and I'm
thinking two things are going to happen
the meth head is going to think I'm
crazy and take off running or a 25 foot
long Nile crocodile is going to come
flying down the alley and eat them and
then I continue a good but what I didn't
count on is the meth head being a nature
show freak like me and countering my
baby alligator noises with his very own
baby koala sound and then he starts
going and I'm just like I'm like Oh cute
cute baby come on then I just give him
my wallet because he wins me over with
cuteness yeah that is a good joke it's
just weird because I when I first did it
I didn't expect it to be a keeper
because I thought no one's gonna know
that baby alligators make noises and and
so now I'm starting to think that either
some people know or some people think
I'm just making it up but either way
it's so ridiculous they're laughing well
I one of those jokes that I never
thought would connect and it did so I
got lucky in a way or on the other hand
to you could also have a bunch of people
that are closeted nature watchers that
are going oh [ __ ] that's exactly what
the baby alligators has like and they're
like holy crap and that's what makes
them laugh but I love that Oh
man yes and that's a newbie that I'm
doing so now how long have you been in
Hollywood now I came to LA and 8088 I
think why are 89 yeah I've been here a
long time man yeah I came out here in 84
during the Summer Olympics oh wow yeah
and this is how much do you think this
city's changed that's the problem with
LA it doesn't change at all like I know
think it's changed I don't well you mean
like like metaphysically or spiritually
or Jimi physically I mean physically
physically I Drive by the same trees the
same worn-out buildings the same I don't
see a lot of change in this town it's
weird you don't get very far from your I
Drive all over this town really I find
it just like what do you find changing
well I mean right down at the bottom of
your street is like this big huge you
know is like whatever the current where
crunch fitness and the the Trader Joe's
and all used to be that used to be the
Schwab's drugstore oh well you're
talking like that the Schwab's drugstore
was like back during the Depression oh
that was there an 85 oh well see I
didn't get here till 80 88 or any nice
all right I'll give you that are you but
to me a lot doesn't change here and it
makes me sad because a lot of the houses
a lot of the buildings it's a very
dilapidated old tired looking City a lot
of strip malls that are the same and I
just feel like that this city is a
little behind it's like because you
don't have the weather you don't have
snow and a lot of people just kind of
leave everything well I passed the same
houses like I used to live in another
house on Laurel Canyon a very busy
street like 20 years ago and I Drive by
it and it's the plants are the same the
chipped paints the same and I find a lot
of buildings here just never really
change unless the home puts up something
new but once something's up it seems to
just be the same yeah what I've been up
here place a few times I don't notice a
lots changed yeah thank you but but
that's great
so now
a lot of people have like you know like
I love to play golf a lot of people have
their hobbies they're here they get you
got to have something that keeps you
busy yeah is there something it there's
there's something you love to do that
keeps you besides besides uh scalloping
you know and I want to get I'll get to
that in a minute I want to get I'll get
to floor it in a minute but I want but
but you told me a joke about scalloping
but I will leave that alone
yeah yeah but but what is their big
hobby you have here well yeah as you
know me and you played a crap ton of
Records oh yeah nice you stopped but I
kept playing me and court would play
probably two three times a week at one
point
yeah and court was amazing I think out
of you know 70 games I probably be court
five times but I learned a little bit I
wouldn't say five maybe one no no you
you one more probably if lucky probably
ten out ten of those but still man we we
had a blast but then court I think a
little tired of it but I kept because
you have golf but I play racquetball
every week and then the other hobby I
have is you know I do work on my own
podcast the Harlan Highway at that I do
mind twice a week so that takes up a lot
of time and that's I've been doing that
I think coming up on seven years because
you first started and I want to talk
about the Harlan Highway because you've
been on it you're on the same network as
we are you're on all things comedy
network and you started this as kind of
wasn't it a radio show in Denver yeah
Risley I did the drive home show in
Denver from like 3:00 to 7:00 from LA
from LA so I had to produce eight comedy
bits a day and email them and then they
would slot them in in between songs so
it sounded like I was there but I owned
the bit so by the time my year contract
was up I had a thousand like fully
produced comedy bits for audio you know
I was like major the mind stuff and so
right around that time when I finished
doing the radio the podcasting started
emerging right so I was just using those
bits that I own and dropping them into a
podcast and then I'd talk for a bit then
drop in a bit talk some more and and so
was kind of like a perfect segue into
podcasting so I was one of the original
probably out of all the comedians who
started podcasting I was probably right
there at the start like the original
eight or seven or five you know me and
Corolla and Mark Marin and yeah I think
even Joe Rogan came along a lot later
but so I was there right right at the
beginning of it almost it's amazing to
me to think that you would do a show
like how did that come about doing the
drive the afternoon drive for a Denver
radio station what happened as I was
doing a show at the Denver Comedy Club
The Comedy Works raid Club
yeah great club and I went in to do a
morning interview with with the number
one radio station in the city these guys
and they just loved me and the guys who
ran the station we're listening to me
just kind of riff it on the morning show
and they approached me after and said
hey man would you like your own show and
I said what are you talking about they
said you know we want to want to you
know make a change at the drive home
spot would you be willing if we bought
you all the equipment and you know gave
you some money and blah blah blah would
you would you want to you know be the
host of the drive home show and I was
like hell yeah so so I ended up doing it
for a year that's a lot of work though
it was a lot of work I like I said I had
to do eight comedy bits a day and send
them in so I had to come up with one now
eight bit you know if you might think oh
that's nothing but no that's that's like
writing eight new jokes a day like I was
like under the gun it was a lot of work
but it was due on I do one a month yeah
what do children talk to find a keeper
but but you know sometimes when you
force to do stuff you'd be amazed what
happened so it just so that's where that
came from and then I was able to like I
say use that stuff and put it into a
podcast
after I finished now if you guys want to
check it out and I highly recommend
checking out it's the Harlan Highway
it's on all things comedy you can also
go to Harlan Williams calm and there's a
link to the Harlan highway through true
and we also have an app for the
Heartland highway if you go on your cell
phone and your App Store type in the
Harlan Highway free app you can listen
to us
anywhere yeah now I'm just jealous oh
well you'll get one you'll get one yeah
that's okay um uh I'll keep I'm the only
one allowed with the app yeah that's
pretty cool yeah that's a good deal
yeah so now what do you have coming up
what's coming up for Harlan I know
because you've got caramel corn you're
in the middle of editing and putting
that all together are you going back out
on the road with your new with the new
stuff now yep going on the road hitting
the road the end of September you can
look at all my stand-up dates at Harlan
Williams com going to be going to
Chicago going to be going to Portland
going to be going to San Jose going to
be going to her vine gonna be going all
over the place so just check out my
website and see if I'm coming to your
city and there's links to everything you
can order your tickets right online
there you go
yeah man listen I can't thank you enough
for being a guest on this podcast always
a pleasure
so really mellow so easygoing it's like
you can catch me next week I will be in
Reno at the Reno Tahoe comedy club
August 3rd through the 5th you can go to
court McGowan at court McAllen or
Twitter at court McAllen on Instagram
there's links to all that stuff there or
go to Reno
reno/tahoe comedy comm something like
that I Sereno tahoe comedy we'll hook it
up listen thanks again buddy thank you
buddy I appreciate it thanks for having
the old man it's always good to have the
old man this is in sensitivity training
I'm court McHale don't forget to check
out at Joe bartnick check out his dates
he's going all through Canada look him
up don't forget to email us court and
Joe at gmail.com everybody have a great
week
you